i'm ready to take my devops career to  the next level have you considered  google cloud professional devops  engineer certification tell me more  about the devops engineering role itself  a professional cloud devops engineer is  basically responsible for efficient  deployment operations balancing service  reliability and delivery speed they are  skilled at using the google cloud tools  to build ci cd pipelines and monitor and  manage them are there prerequisites to  approach the exam it's recommended that  you have about three years of industry  experience including maybe one year of  managing solutions on google cloud any  advice on where i should get started  there are tons of training resources  from sample questions to hands-on labs  and on-demand courses check them out and  did i mention you will receive a digital  badge an online certificate and  swag  you